[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas le meilleur meeting qui était
fait par les républicains depuis depuis
depuis toutes ces années évidemment
alors que valérie pécresse par la
tribune nadine morano s'exclame
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est pas
possible et pendant les silences marquée
de la candidate c'est hervé morin patron
des centristes qui s'écrit
accélère valérie accélère si vous voulez
des beaux parleurs vous en avez plein
dans cette campagne si vous voulez
quelqu'un qui fait je crois qu'il ya pas
bon c'est pas vrai qu'il est pas bonne
en coaching je vous rappelle emmanuel
macron en 2010 est en train de beugler
au micro personne n'a dit que c'est un
piètre orateur ce qui du coup a plutôt
fait insupportable de s'en prendre à
savoir je dirais manuel macron s'est
envolé dans les aigus ça n'empêche pas
de présider la france
c'est pas sa forme favorite les g et f
ce qui est incroyable c'est le lynchage
médiatique auquel on assiste aujourd'hui
de naufrage un petit peu comme le
titanic et ça tombe bien puisque on
s'est rendu compte que jack dawson était
là à regarder bien et lui dit valérie un
toit iceberg droit devant même dans les
milieux qui sont les nôtres qui sont des
milieux de gens qui ont quand même
beaucoup diplômes et autres il ya encore
un petit fond de sauce misogyne qui
m'impressionne vous avez écouté son
discours plus ou moins parce que c'est
pas facile de suivre un quinté mais à ce
niveau d'expression orale j'ai trouvé
que valérie pécresse il n'y a vait été
sincère et authentique
et je suis persuadé qu'elle a trouvé en
elle la force pour convaincre les
français que son projet pour notre pays
était le meilleur certain nombre de deux
parties probablement à un moment donné à
force de trop de deux langues
de bois abouti c'est une gueule de bois
au moment des élections cette ligne elle
était fortement exprimée représenter un
carnet hier donc sur le fond de ce
discours est là et quand même
l'essentiel arrêtons avec le superficiel
c'est vrai que ces thématiques là d'un
électorat de droite porte une
conséquence et donc de ce point de vue
là elle revient sur beaucoup de choses
qu'elle a dit jusqu'à présent je ne la
voyais pas de dérivés comme cela elle
dérive je peux me permettre l'expression
qu'elle ne prendra pas mal je l'espère
elle ne sait plus où elle habite tous
les commentateurs qui la reprennent ont
des mémoires de bigorneaux j'ai dit dix
fois dans la primaire dans la primaire
de la droite que je ne me résigne ni au
grand remplacement ni aux grands des
classes normand ça veut dire je ne me
résigne pas ajustement aux théories
d'eric zemmour alors est ce un clin
d'oeil à la droite de la droite selon
anne hidalgo ça ne fait pas de doute
c'est un rubicon de plus qui est
franchie par la droite qui aurait pu
être cette droite républicaine mais qui
prend une référence de l'extrême droite
et un mot pour décrire ce choix
sémantique la sidération de voir une
candidate qui se dit républicaine
reprendre les mots de l'extrême droite
ces concepts je suis pas sûr qu'avec une
telle dérive madame pécresse au second
tour
avoir repris tout le registre sémantique
et idéologie d'extrême droite
franchement nous avions déjà de gagner
d'extrême droite n'avait pas bonne après
une troisième à 5 kg a été assassiné
pour les petits comme à daytona
pour qui voter dallas mange le niveau
est quand même effrayante humour prof la
même chose sauf que il a une différence
avec le pen est peut-être c'est ici
c'est la différence la plus perverse
c'est que seymour et juif mondial or
c'est à dire qu'en fait il fait le jeu
de service pour les antisémites les
masques tombent monsieur jadot tombe là
où il devait tomber voilà on voit bien
que son discours pseudo modéré n'était
qu'un discours attrape gogo le mauvais
juif ça me choque pas du tout c'est près
d'ailleurs de toute la campagne de diane
y sommes c'est la phrase la plus
intéressante